[Music]  one of the things that anyone will  notice when they work in alexa ai  is the amazing group of scientists and  engineers that we have around here so  there's lots to learn nowadays more and  more machine learning techniques are  being applied across different domains  which means that we see a lot of  researchers with completely different  backgrounds joining us in tts the  customers  they are placed at the forefront of  every decision we make and so if there  is any character or skill you think that  would enable you to be customer obsessed  that's a plus one alexa is a fantastic  place for anyone who wants to work on  solving real-world practical problems  with deep learning in the speech and  natural language understanding space  there's plenty of opportunities to  innovate and build state-of-the-art  solutions for some of these problems  [Music]